and so just just to recap uh gilan
maxwell has been found guilty of five of
the six charges against her including
that most serious sex trafficking charge
she faces for that charge alone a
maximum of 40 years in prison
one thing to note with all these
different charges five of the six she's
found guilty of is that these sentences
sentencing will be decided at a later
date but these sentences can be served
either consecutively or concurrently
that will be decided um at a later date
but certainly gilan maxwell
will almost certainly spend the rest of
her life in prison she turned 60 years
old in prison just last week on
christmas day her family have long
complained um about the conditions they
say she was subject she's been subjected
to
over the past 18 months while she's been
in prison at the metropolitan detention
center in brooklyn just across the river
from here but it seems certain that
she'll spend many many more years and as
i say almost certainly the rest of her
life in prison in the united states
gillen maxwell three of her siblings
were inside there to hear
that verdict being handed down and she
has six surviving siblings all in all
she was the youngest
of nine maxwell children she's the
daughter of the disgraced billionaire
billionaire financier robert maxwell she
actually made her home new york after
robert maxwell's death friends those
close to guillen maxwell said that she
went from uh
from the hands of robert maxwell into
the arms of jeffrey epstein
and that she was infatuated by jeffrey
epstein many people describe it as an
unequal relationship that she was very
much in love with him and perhaps he
didn't have the same affection for her
the prosecution case and throughout this
trial has been that there were two
sexual predators
in that relationship that yes it may
have been predominantly jeffrey epstein
carrying out the physical acts of sexual
abuse but on occasion guillen maxwell
joined in too and the women who took the
stand all four of them say that they
came from broken homes to some extent
they say that guillen maxwell identified
their frailties and that was how she was
able to encourage them um to
go to jeffrey epstein's various mansions
that it was her charm and her magnetism
that made them feel safe in his presence
so
the jury certainly siding with the the
prosecution's case here